April in Seville
it's hot but women are wearing long
sleeves men are in suits the locals love
to dress up for the festival for six
days in a row they dance eat and drink
visitors either take a carriage or
stroll through the city it's important
to see and be seen but friends and
family are the priority for us it's a
week we can't miss at any cost we look
forward to it all year round women
dancing flamenco are more enchanting
than anything else in the world
it's a typical Spanish festival in
Seville more than one thousand tens have
been pitched called casitas most belong
to families clubs or professional
associations only invited guests get in
members pay thousands of euros a year
and pass on their cassettes to their
children and grandchildren others have
to wait 20 years to get their own casita
for locals such as peel a banana aiya
this is the occasion to spend time with
good friends and acquaintances if they
invite you to Cosette it's as if they've
invited you to their home
sometimes people are tourists into
family considers that are actually
private in this sense Seville
inhabitants are really very open um say
exclusivity is why de faria has remained
a local festival but there are some
tourists
apart from beer and wine people like to
drink rebel hito sherry was lemonade
tourists who had their fill of street
entertainment can get something to eat
or drink in a public casita and the
lucky ones might even get invited to a
private tent
imitation to cut off bright flamenco
dresses are a key component of the Feria
founded in 1847 it was a cattle market
that gradually became more and more of a
festival and a catwalk for flamenco this
year black and red are trendy and long
fringes men also wear traditional garb a
short jacket and a hat called a
córdoba's other regional costumes in
Spain remained the same but here there
are always new trends if you want to
wear the same dress two times in a row
you should definitely change something
add something new
while some party others have to work for
the designer
Rocio Montero the Feria means big
business a customer from Valencia is
coming on the weekend and her new dress
has to be finished in time the
family-owned company Lena has been
making flamenco dresses for over 50
years
Grace Kelly was one of their customers a
tailor-made dress starts out at about
800 euros
if I had a flamenco dress has to have
flounces and a skirt that's good for
dancing a number of frills their size
and where they're attached changes from
one year to the next and from one
designer to the next the other thing is
that it should be close fitting so a
woman can dance well that's the point
after all the failure would simply not
be the same without the silviana it's
light-hearted music and dance are
popular all over Spain and it's a far
cry from the much heavier flamenco in
fact earlier the men used it to court
the ladies